good morning believe nation today's
message is find your why over to you
Kevin Spacey me go how can we help us
appreciate this early experience these
lean years these very difficult years
leading up to the ultimate prize there
is no prize out there the only prize is
this one and what you feel and what you
want to accomplish and if you can as you
start out these what could be lean years
or could be fat ears I feel that I very
often watch a lot of young people sort
of meander around without any idea about
why they're doing what they're doing I
mean to want and to be ambitious and to
want to be successful is not enough
that's just desire to know what you want
to understand why you're doing it to
dedicate every breath in your body to
achieve if you feel you have something
to give if you feel that your particular
talent is worth developing is worth
caring for
then there's nothing you can't achieve
what I really loved about this message
is that the prize isn't out there the
gold isn't out there the you know cheban
is it out there it's here it's inside
and what it comes down to for me is yes
finding the why and at the same time
enjoy the process too many people have a
goal to go out and get rich and drive
fancy cars and buy that brand new
amazing house built from scratch custom
build house and I'll do anything to get
there I'll do whatever crap you want me
to do as long as I get that outcome and
that's the wrong way to go about things
if you look at the most successful
people we've heard this again how many
times from actors to entrepreneurs and
inventors across the board people enjoy
the work there is no end goal you love
the process of what you're doing and you
can only force yourself to do something
for so long before you give up on it
like that outcome that goal isn't strong
enough for you to deal with all of this
crap that you have to go through instead
recognize that the real the real benefit
is you doing work that you love you
doing work that you can pour your heart
and soul and energy into you doing
something that you're so proud of that
you want to show off to your parents and
to your grandkids and save it for future
generations say look what I made look
what I was a part of but what I built
having that kind of pride and passion
and pouring it into the work instead of
just mailing it in and doing what the
customer wants and just kind of barely
getting by blow people away create
something that people want to look at
it's so spectacular and so different and
so new that I've never seen it before
because you have invested so much of
your art into making it come to fruition
that's where people when they tap into
their genius level talent and apply it
that's when they start to see massive
success if you're just doing what people
are asking you when doing the bare
minimum and just getting by then you're
just going to get by in life as well and
your business is just going to get by as
well stop having so many external
focuses and focus on why you're doing
this and making something that you can
be proud of and enjoying not every
single moment of every single day you're
going to have down parts in your
business and in life
but net net enjoying the process the
creation I love making these videos if I
was doing it just to try to get to a
million subscribers I would have quit a
long time ago I love Wednesday this is
my feeling day I come in I'm looking
forward to it all week I love coming
here and talking to you guys I'm making
these videos for you it's for you and
it's for me I love the process and as
long as I love it i'm gonna keep doing
it and the second that i stopped loving
it second that I lose interest like ah
oh I got to go in and fill them again
it's over I'll quit and go do something
else because you will never do great
things when you don't have a great
mindset and attitude that you're
pointing to the work to create it so the
question today today is what is your why
leave in the comments below I'm gonna
join in the discussion I also want to
give a quick shadow to mia Park MOEA
thank you so much you're buying a copy
of my book really deeply means a lot to
me those are you watching you want your
chance at a shout out in the future
video make sure to a couple copy of the
book and email in your seat so we can
keep track and send you the bonuses
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and i'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot events vessel oh wait spray so keep
me